antoine bonjour le club valdaï entame
donc ses travaux aujourd'hui quel est le
programme de la journée
oui c'est une nouvelle édition du club
valdaï qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui à moscou
et qui a pour thème le moyen-orient à
l'ère du changement vers une nouvelle
architecture de stabilité durant
plusieurs ateliers conférences une
cinquantaine d'intervenants de 20 pays
des chercheurs des enseignants des
responsables politiques vont tour à tour
prendre la parole débattre des grandes
problématiques du moyen-orient l
actualité concernant cette région du
monde et particulièrement riche en ce
moment on peut penser en particulier au
plan de paix américain concernant le
conflit israélo palestinien
l' escalade militaire en syrie entre les
armées turque et syrienne ou encore la
situation en libye où le sort l'avenir
de l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien
ce ne sont pas les sujets de discussion
qui manquent l'objectif sera donc de
débattre de ces grandes questions mais
aussi de promouvoir la résolution
pacifique de ces conflits dans une
région du monde qui cristallise toutes
les tensions
antoine claireaux en direct de moscou
merci pour toutes ces précisions